Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This paper is from the Google DeepMind guys,
and is about teaching neural networks to be
capable of relational reasoning.
This means that we can present the algorithm
with an image and ask it relatively complex
relational questions.
For instance, if we show it this image and
ask "What is the color of the object that
is closest to the blue object?", it would
answer "red".
This is a particularly difficult problem because
all the algorithm has access to is a bunch
of pixels.
In computer code, it is near impossible to
mathematically express that in an image, something
is below or next to something else, especially
in 3 dimensional scenes.
Beyond a list of colors, this requires a cognitive
understanding of the entirety of the image.
This is something that we humans are amazingly
good at, but computer algorithms are dreadful
for this type of work.
And this work almost feels like teaching common
sense to a learning algorithm.
This is accomplished by augmenting and already
existing neural network with a relational
network module.
This is implemented on top of a recurrent
neural network that we call long short-term
memory or LSTM, that is able to process sequences
of information, for instance, an input sentence.
The more seasoned Fellow Scholars know that
we've talked about LSTMs in earlier episodes,
and of course, as always, the video description
contains these episodes for your enjoyment.
Make sure to have a look, you'll love it.
As you can see in this result, this relational
reasoning also works for three dimensional
scenes as well.
The aggregated results in the paper show that
this method is not only leaps and bounds beyond
the capabilities of already existing algorithms,
but, and now, hold on to your papers - in
many cases, it also shows superhuman performance.
I love seeing these charts in machine learning
papers where several learning algorithms and
humans are benchmarked on the same tasks.
This paper was barely published and there
is already a first, unofficial public implementation
and two research papers have already referenced
it.
This is such a great testament to the incredible
pace of machine learning research these days.
To say that it is competitive would be a huge
understatement.
Achieving high quality results in relational
reasoning is an important cornerstone for
achieving general intelligence, and even though
there are still much, much more to do, today
is one of those days when we can feel that
we're a part of the future.
The failure cases are also reported in the
paper and are definitely worthy of your time
and attention.
When I asked for permissions to cover this
paper in the series, all three scientists
from DeepMind happily answered yes within
30 minutes.
That's unbelievable.
Thanks guys!
Also, some of these questions sound like ones
that we would get in the easier part of an
IQ test.
I wouldn't be very surprised to see a learning
algorithm complete a full IQ test with flying
colors in the near future.
If you enjoyed this episode, and you feel
that 8 of these videos a month is worth a
dollar, please consider supporting us on Patreon.
This way, we can make better videos for your
enjoyment.
We've recently reached a new milestone, which
means that part of these funds will be used
to empower research projects.
Details are available in the video description.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time.